فين السعوديه سالنا الجمهور كاس العالم ما
اكثر ما ستفتقده بعد نهايه الموضوع
[موسيقى]
كاس العالم بصراحه لانه جوا ما تتفوت
الاماكن كلها مليانه الكافيهات المطاعم
الكل بينتظره اللحظه اللي بيشوف فيهم بركه
العالم لانه اللحظات صراحه تحتاج الى
الواحد وتوقف عندها ويستمتع هذه اللحظات
ما تحصل الا كل اربع سنين اكيد
اكيد جدا
السعوديه تاهل والكاس العالم
العربي والحماس يعني اول ما فازت المغرب
على طول كل الكل راح الكورنيش همم كان
حماس وانبسطنا كلنا
ليونيل ميسي
بعد اربع سنوات التجمعات اللي كانت هناك
والروح الرياضيه وكل شيء كان حلو هناك
ميسي
اللاعب الكبير اللي كلنا نحبه كريستيانو
عشان هيعتذر هيكون اخر كاس عالم
الكوره واحبها كريستيانو